[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce journal d'information locale
elle nous sommes le lundi 25 octobre
voici les titres de cette édition du 20
au 30 octobre la ville de plaisir
organise sa semaine de la citoyenneté au
programme rallye collecte ateliers ou
encore expositions le but comprendre les
différents services municipaux et
apprendre à vivre ensemble et à devenir
la des citoyens responsables une
opération nationale à la découverte des
labels c'est ce qu'a organisé greenpeace
samedi une dizaine de militants s'est
rassemblée à montigny le bretonneux
objectifs de leur présence sensibiliser
et informer sur l'impact environnemental
et socio-économiques et des labels la
quatrième édition de leur solidaire et
lancer un événement organisé par le
réseau d'associations habitat humanisme
partout en france le principe de donner
une heure de son temps aux plus démunis
pour l'occasion un atelier culinaire
était organisée à jouy en josas avec
thierry marx et puis dans le reste de
l'actualité à plus de 90% des yvelinois
disposent de leur schéma vaccinal
complet et résultat à l'activité des
centres de vaccination ralenti après
plus de 1 million sept cent trente huit
mille injections réalisées dont le
département un centre réalise à présent
moins de 800 injection par semaine en
moyenne est de ce fait au 1er novembre
seuls six centres resteront ouvertes
dans les yvelines ceux de versailles
bonnières sur seine saint quentin en
yvelines sartrouville ou encore menthe
et les mais nulle une information
annoncée à par la préfecture dans un
communiqué il est par ailleurs par
ailleurs toujours possible de se faire
vacciner auprès de professionnels de
santé tels que les pharmaciens ou encore
les médecins
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre jusqu'au
30 octobre la ville de plaisir organise
sa semaine de la citoyenneté l'objectif
à travers cet événement de venir à des
citoyens responsables et justement avec
nous pourrons parler joséphine et à
coleman ce berger maire de plaisir
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
alors pourquoi instaurer déjà cette
semaine de la citoyenneté et côté des
gens parce que je pense qu'une puis
collectivités une ville mais même à pays
bas c'est un endroit où l'on vit c'est
un endroit où on partage avec les autres
et il nous semblait important
par rapport à ce qui se passe en ce
moment on a pu voir même je dirais dans
la presse les problématiques qui ce que
les gens vivent il ya des agressions
avaient auprès des élus mais il ya aussi
toute une série d'articles sur le
comportement des gens les incivilités
les rodéos en ford entend parler de ça
toute la journée et on se disait que
quoi de mieux que de consacrer une
semaine entière à la citoyenneté en
peut-être sensibilisant toutes les toute
la population du plus petit au plus
grand et donc dans cette semaine de la
citoyenneté beaucoup d'animations sont
prévues des expositions des collectes ou
encore des ateliers est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un peu plus en détail
de ce programme mais côté on est un
programme très chargé puisque nous avons
pratiquement tous les jours des
activités regardez j'ai devant moi ça
peut paraître anecdotique mais j'ai
devant moi un jolie coque nous en avons
fourni à la fois aux enfants et aux
adultes qui sont venus chercher ces
coques pour les décors et les mettre
dans dans les vitrines des commerçants
alors on dirait c'est peut-être plus
gadget mais on a surtout des rencontres
avec la police la police municipale mais
national également pour faire toute une
série d'animations auprès des jeunes
pour leur montrer comment on doit par
exemple se servir avec sécurité d'une
d'un vélo sur la route et partager ça
avec les voitures et puis les
trottinettes on a ça on vous avez pu
aussi constater peut-être en tout cas
une grande campagne que nous avons mises
en place sur la ville une campagne à peu
thomas guillot madame le maire quand
même allé un peu trash autre campagne
parce que on a eu des inscriptions un
petit peu forte sur mes moutons permis
ou bien merci pour les crottes
excusez-moi de d'employés mais c'est
notre campagne c'est pour un petit peu
marqué aussi les habitants en leur
disant envoyés la semaine de la
citoyenneté oui c'est un titre mais
c'est pas que ça c'est aussi des actions
autour je dirais du comportement de tous
les jours on a aussi notre marianne la
marianne qui représente notre république
française il va y avoir aussi toute une
exposition avec des gens qui vont venir
prendre des photos avec la marianne pour
pourquoi pas être un jour la
représentation de notre marianne de ceux
comme vous le savez il ya eu pas mal
d'artistes quillan il en guise en place
il y aura aussi toute une distribution
de vêtements pour des jeunes ados avec
des partages avec deux associations
plaisir vestiaire qui va aussi
participer à ça et puis on a un grand
goûter festif et participatif à la fin
de la semaine pour réunir tout le monde
surtout toutes ces démarches nos que
nous allons faire ensemble
donc voilà c'est un programme très dense
qui est dans cette première semaine de
vacances et je crois que ça marche très
très bien parce que ne serait ce que
pour la décoration des coptes on en a
distribué plus d'une centaine il en
manque presse mais aussi parce que dans
les maisons des familles dans avec le
ccas nous avons énormément de discussion
avec la population qui vient à nous et
on peut échanger sur toutes ces
problématiques qui gérait perturber le
quotidien des habitants vous même vous
allez donner des interviews notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux pourquoi
pourrait lier votre rôle peut-être la
barre dans l'important c'était de
rencontrer les enfants c'est là qu'on
commence je dirais pour cette
sensibilisation au niveau de la
citoyenneté et donc j'ai rencontré une
vingtaine de jeunes des petits qui sont
venus me poser des question
effectivement c'est en ligne aujourd'hui
sur nos réseaux et sur le site de la
ville les enfants m'ont posé des
questions sur qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
maire
qu'est ce qui se passe si le maire me
voilà on a un mois j'ai pas voulu filtré
du tout les questions il ya eu aussi des
questions sur comment ça se passe car
quel âge on peut être mais on fait toute
une série de questions qui ont été
posées par des enfants qui ont été
choisis par eux c'était une façon aussi
de venir ici à l'hôtel de ville qui est
un lieu ouvert à tous et puis essayer
avec eux de répondre à des questions qui
peut être
sont compliquées pour donc a eu tout ça
et ce sont des petits films de une
minute qui ont beaucoup plu aux enfants
et à moi aussi j'avoue que c'était
vraiment un très très beau roman et puis
on a quand même notre notre notre grande
assemblée citoyenne qui regroupe plus de
40 personnes qui travaillent en
permanence avec nous qu'ils sont des
citoyens qui font partie de cette âpre
semblait citoyenne c'est lé tout nouveau
sur plaisir même si on faisait beaucoup
de concertation et il travaille
actuellement en lien avec les seniors de
la ville justement pour ce fameux label
l'est de la ville les seniors mais tout
ça ça fait partie je dirais de notre
proximité en tant qu'élu auprès de la
population pour leur démontrer que
effectivement nous avons des droits en
tant que citoyens mais nous avons aussi
des devoirs et ces bilatérales et nous
les élus on est là pour les accompagner
vous en parliez déjà tout à l'heure dans
le programme et durera donc un mur des
incivilités et un atelier graff qui sont
qui sont prévus pour s'exprimer
notamment vous disiez sur les
dégradations les déjections canines les
déchets dont que le respect et le non
respect d'autrui est-ce qu'il s'agit
plus de prévention se sont à des choses
qu'on rencontre régulièrement sur la
commune de de plaisir et c'est pour ça
qu'on essaie de lutter contre je pense
que rencontre sa plus sur notre commune
que sur une autre commune puisque pour
échanger avec les maires ne se fasse que
de l'agglomération mais également du
département je m'aperçois que ce lâcher
prise un petit peu des sensibilités des
papiers lâcher des bigots un peu partout
une petite section canine que l'on
trouve aussi un peu partout ça fait
partie malheureusement de notre
quotidien mais parfois il faut un peu
choqué donc choqué dans le bon sens du
terme mais le grave par exemple
je vous avoue que sur la ville de
plaisir on n'a pas tellement de grave
sauvage sur cette collectivité on a fait
pas ça fait d'ailleurs depuis très très
longtemps au niveau des dessins et des
graves sur les murs on en a fait plutôt
dollar puisque comme vous le savez dans
le quartier du val hibou nous avons des
fresques monumentales qui ont été faites
aussi en collaboration avec les élus et
on a aussi un graffeur qui travaille
avec nos jeunes de la ville pour pouvoir
justement exprimé dollar sur les murs
plutôt que des grèves sauvages mais on
n'en a pas trop parce qu'on a mis en
place aussi une réaction immédiate
c'est-à-dire que dès qu'il ya un grave
on le met on les fasse tout de suite
quand justement ne pas attirer d'autres
graff mais c'est plutôt pour accompagner
tout cela d'une façon artistique et
citoyenne
vous l'aurez compris donc une semaine de
la citoyenneté pour faire ressortir les
valeurs citoyennes plus d'informations
sur le site de la mairie qui s'est
affichée en bas de l'écran merci
beaucoup madame commons berger joséphine
coleman se marie davoy était avec nous
au maire de la commune de plaisir merci
à merci infiniment est venu nombreux
merci avec plaisir
et on reste sur la semaine de la
citoyenneté de plaisir c'est peut-être
la collectivité locale la plus connue
c'est la mairie qu'elle soit celle d'une
petite ou d'une grande commune la mairie
à de nombreuses compétences sécurité
action sociale santé ou encore enfance
jeunesse je vous propose de faire un
tour d'horizon de ses compétences avec
mélanie poké
au 1er janvier 2020 à la france compte
35 mille 54 communes 90% d'entre elles
ont moins de trente deux mille habitants
et depuis 1884 elles sont gérées par le
conseil municipal par le maire elles ont
à leur charge de nombreuses compétences
la plus connue c'est sans doute la
gestion de l'état civil la mairie
enregistre les mariages les naissances
et les décès et c'est aussi en mairie
que vous devez vous rendre pour
renouveler votre carte d'identité à
condition que la mairie soit équipé
d'une station d'enregistrement
à noter aussi que ce sont les communes
qui organisent les élections qu'il
s'agisse des révisions des listes
électorales la gestion des bureaux de
vote ou encore les envois des résultats
en préfecture la commune a aussi
compétence en matière de sécurité le
maire est le garant de l'ordre public il
doit assurer le bon ordre la
tranquillité et la salubrité publique il
est aidé par la police municipale ou les
gardes champêtres quand il s'agit d'une
morales il exerce ses pouvoirs sous le
contrôle administratif du préfet et du
tribunal administratif
du côté de l'enseignement primaire la
ville est propriétaire des locaux des
écoles publiques établies sur son
territoire c'est à dire qu'elle en
assure la construction les grandes
réparations mais aussi l'entretien elle
organise la restauration scolaire dont
elles fixent la participation financière
des familles elle gère aussi les
personnels non enseignants comme les
atsem peut-être un peu moins connus la
compétence liés à l'urbanisme la commune
et la banc le plan local d'urbanisme le
fameux pl lui la commune peut par
exemple décidé d'empêcher des
constructions pour des raisons
architecturales historique et elle
délivre aussi les permis de conduire
voilà une petite liste non exhaustive de
compétence de la mairie
[Musique]
une journée de mobilisation nationale
pour greenpeace samedi à l'entrée du
centre commercial de saint quentin en
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux des
membres du groupe local greenpeace
versailles ont organisé une animation
objectif sensibiliser et informer la
population sur les labels un reportage
de nicolas landry une roue des labels
voilà l'activité proposée par greenpeace
que ce soit la case agriculture
biologique appellation d'origine
protégée ou label rouge
tous ont des caractéristiques
particulières
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est de
sensibiliser et d'informer la population
sur ce critère parce qu'aujourd'hui il
existe un flou sur les labels un label
une garantie sur l'origine la qualité
des méthodes de production encore les
caractéristiques sociales et
environnementales d'un produit
alimentaire à l'origine de cette journée
de sensibilisation
une étude sur onze label les critères
sociaux économiques et environnementaux
à partir des cahiers des charges ont été
analysés par greenpeace
abdoulaye il protège un peu
l'environnement et il protège bien les
travailleurs et pour aller vers les
consommateurs
par contre que le label rouge pour bah
non c'est un cahier des charges qui est
un peu vide on a par exemple
label rouge du port qui est assez
très mal par rapport à son époque et un
gros mental et économique de temps en
temps c'est un peu compliqué tu y
retrouver parce que il ya tellement de
la belle que des fonds se dit ah quel
label prend 2 quel est le mieux pour
notre santé pour l'environnement est
vrai qu'on a un peu de mal à s'y
retrouver de temps en temps ça et que ça
c'est compliqué d'après un sondage elle
s à 2 mars 2021 80 % des français
interrogés ont déclaré chercher
régulièrement des informations sur le
lieu d'origine du produit
et jusqu'au 31 octobre l'association
habitat et humanisme lance la 4ème
édition de leur solidaire personnalité
tout public et entreprises sont invitées
à donner une heure en dons ou de leur
temps à pour les plus démunis pour
l'occasion thierry marx organisait un
atelier culinaire à jouy saint john à
jouy en josas le reportage de ces diaga
tsonga et mickaël millero
une personnalité qui donne une heure de
son temps pour faire partager son métier
avec les plus démunis l'association
habitat et humanisme a organisé un
atelier culinaire à la pension de
famille des jouets en josas en présence
dé thierry marx le seuil de partager ma
passion et finalement l'écouté là et ils
les échanges sont deviennent passionnant
la recette du jour pain d'épicés aux
pommes rôties elle avait été élaboré à
paris saclay pour le premier repas de
thomas pesquet dans l'espace objectif
apprendre à travailler les produits et
ne pas les surdoses et j'aimerais qu'ils
refassent mersey déçoit qui comprennent
la philosophie la philosophie de la
recette c'est à dire de ne pas gâcher
les produits qui ne sont donnés et ne
pas perdre 30% d'une orange ne pas
perdre 30% d une pomme parce qu'on croit
que c'est des déchets alors que c'est
des cons produit et je vais curan
gradient décembre
en fait chez cuir vite
à l'occasion du passage à l'heure
d'hiver qui a lieu ce dimanche 31
octobre la quatrième édition de leur
solidaire a pour but de lutter contre
l'exclusion et l'isolément des personnes
en difficulté l'objectif auprès des
personnes qui ont participé c'est leur
donner un moment de détente de leur
donner l'occasion aussi d'écouter et
d'apprendre par la voix d'un grand chef
ce qu'ils peuvent ce qu'ils peuvent
faire au total une trentaine de
personnes étaient présentes pour suivre
le cours de cuisine des résidents de la
pension de famille et des locataires des
appartements d'habitat et humanisme
chéri mart était quelqu'un de très
professionnel de très très accueillants
et revenant il nous a bien expliqué
comment faut-il posséder pour faire ces
cuisine gastronomique j'ai appris qu'il
y ait des choses le policier m qui peut
aussi comment faire part unique selon
lui la clé les fruits sont intéressants
parce que je ferais mieux d'eau toute
personne peut participer à cette
opération via la plateforme heures
solidaires.org en faisant un bon
d'argent ou bien de temps en
s'inscrivant aux ateliers bénévolat
proposées par l'association
côté sport le tennisman arthur
rinderknecht représentera la france lors
de la coupe davis la phase finale se
déroule du 25 novembre au 5 décembre
sélectionnés par sébastien grosjean
capitaine de l'équipe de france le 65e
joueur mondial a gagné plus de 50 matchs
cette saison il sera présent aux en
autriche aux côtés d'hugo imbert richard
gasquet pierre hugues herbert et nicolas
mahut pour disputer lé match de poule la
france a contra la grande-bretagne et la
république tchèque
et depuis quelques années golfeurs
débutants ou plus confirmés se rassemble
2 lors de la golf expérience une fois
par an des activités en nocturne sont
proposés pour les petits et pour les
plus grands retour sur l'édition 2021
qui avait lieu au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce vendredi 22
octobre le reportage de michael et demi
d'euros et bixente mais rien sont
esteban non je n'avais pas déjà fait
bien des initiations pour découvrir le
golf au fur et à mesure que la nuit est
tombée le practice de l'oiselet du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
s'est remplie pour la gold expérience
c'est l'occasion d'essayer la gestion
j'aime j'aime beaucoup l'objectif c'est
de venir entre amis en famille les
familles ou les amis qui sont débutants
vont pouvoir s'amuser avec une heure un
espace dédié aux enfants différents
ateliers on a des bénévoles qui
encadrent différents ateliers où on va
décomposer les différents coûts est
comme ça le débutant va pouvoir au
travers de la soirée découvrir les
différentes facettes du golfe que ça
soit du petit goût du long jeu sur le
practice ou les d exercice d' approche
pour les joueurs les plus confirmés des
outils d'analysé de swing un concours et
un parcours insolite en nocturne avec
des balles phosphorescente c'est une
première donc c'est un parcours de nuit
on n'a jamais tapé de nuit et ça sent
quand même beaucoup les impressions sont
plus les mêmes et le parcours on va le
découvrir je crois qu'il ya trois trous
j'espère qu'on va s'améliorer au fil au
fil du trou après une précédente édition
au golf isabella de plaisir et une
future au blue green de l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines la golf
expérience devient un rendez vous
récurrent du territoire c'est un rendez
vous récurrent il est d'autant plus
important cette année que nous sommes à
trois ans maintenant des jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 et que à 50 ans les vignes
nous accueilleront la compétition de
golf de paris 2024 ici tout à côté sur
le golf national ce que l'on veut
montrer aujourd'hui c'est que le golf
est bien c'est accessible à tous y
compris pour des petits budgets il faut
casser ces images qui sont d'une autre
époque plus de 300 personnes se sont
rendues à l'événement de ce vendredi 22
octobre l'organisation a même dû ajouter
un second parcours en nocturne en raison
des nombreuses demandes sur l'activité
et pour plus d'information sportive
retrouver le ctu sports présentés à part
michael et demi d'euros juste après ce
journal et après dix ans de travaux la
maison zola rouvre ses portes au public
l'occasion d'inaugurer le premier musée
permanent consacré à l' affaire dreyfus
il sera implanté dans une dépendance de
la propriété acquise par l'écrivain en
1878 un lieu symbolique deux personnages
liés de leur vivant alfred dreyfus
officier victime d'une machination
judiciaire et antisémites en 1894 et
puis emile zola écrivain engagé à dans
la sphère auteur du célèbre article
j'accuse le musée présentera donc des
documents objets ou encore photographie
en lien avec la faire l'inauguration
aura lieu demain mardi 26 octobre à 15h
à médan et ce sera en présence du
président de la république emmanuel
macron c'est la fin de ce journal
d'information merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis très bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]